please welcome to the show the one and
only Jon REEP ladies and gentlemen Jon
REEP what's crackin buddy
we made it yes yes there are sound
effects as well you can they can hear in
the group but we can't hear on skype so
I'm doing great it's so great to
officially meet you via the internet
I've seen you perform so many times here
at the Atlanta punchline in the old and
the new one so it's great to connect
with you yeah that is one of the best
clubs in the entire country it's
legendary so many great comedians have
been through that Club old and new and
I'm happy to be a part of that history
yeah and you're I mean you've had a lot
of success I mean you won last Comic
Standing you've been in a bunch of
movies and of course the the TV
commercial and all that but what I'm
curious about as a comedian I'm tinny
I'm a little over 10 years in now and
people watching go ahead and comment
with questions you'd like John to answer
but I'm gonna selfishly open up with my
few questions here what are scanned
you've like you one of those comics who
has like been on the road for JH your
skill out on the road do you have any
favorite like roads stories or just some
of those like never forget moments
whether with other comedians or just
that happened out on that grind that we
all know yeah yeah of course I mean you
know probably I'll start in the
beginning one of the first memorable
moments of like you know when you start
off doing comedy you find your own
little comedy club you you go there you
do the open mikes and that's like one
level of comedy that you get comfortable
with and then the next level is what can
I take this outside of this room and do
it in another room and the first time I
did that was we made another comedian we
went to it was a one-nighter somewhere
in winston-salem North Carolina it was a
pool hall and when we we were greeted
like this we walked in the door and we
walked up to the guy
the manager and we said something like
oh hi were the comedians for tonight and
he goes oh [ __ ] that's tonight like yeah
okay he goes alright well stay here let
me get you a microphone and like like he
grabs a mic he grabs the speaker he puts
us in a corner and he tell he turns the
jukebox off which immediately made
people mad
and then he told people to finish up
their pool games and and listen to us
and so it was not very warm at all I
remember about 15 minutes into my set
being threatened by a guy with a pool
stick
and and I wrapped it up and just got
done my $50 and got the hell out of how
long into your career was this how many
years this would have been like six
months in you know oh dude yeah like a
guy just brought me with him to do like
15 or 20 minutes before him and I didn't
know what to expect I mean I started at
one of the best clubs as well good
nights and you know what China is really
one of those rooms where they laugh at
everything and when you get used to that
and you go out into the real world and
you realize oh I got to write jokes okay
write stuff that was one of those gigs
yeah and what I would I admire about
your career is you've you've always been
like a self-made hustler from the
beginning and that's what I'm all about
here on this show in my own career is I
like I recently just shot and released
my own comedy special that I released
through my website and I know when you
were coming up still working at the news
channel you actually pretty much do you
did like a three camera shoot shooting
like a half hour that you then sent out
to all these different comedy clubs that
then led to you actually getting to do
comedy full-time but for comedians now
in the current climate would you have
any tips for how like comedians
can kind of get that self-made grit even
in these times and really just create
opportunity out of the situation it's
tougher I think in a way for you guys
even though you've got the advantage of
you know the internet and everyone
having a camera on their phone now
that's just as good the cameras I hijack
from the TV and the VHS and all that
yeah but a weird way the technology is
better for you guys but but it's also
harder to develop I think as a feature
comedian because it's hard to get work
as a feature I mean you start off open
mic and maybe hosting shows getting
around 15-20 minutes but but the art of
a good feature is kind of it's harder to
come by now because what happens is you
know headliners today or just bringing
their own guys their own feature acts
people they know people that had
relationships with us in the past and
and if not then the club will just
supply a local guy to do 15 or 20 so
it's harder for you guys as features to
get work but the technology's there but
but that stuff I would say don't i mean
record as much as you can you know
you're set and don't be too eager to
share it because i've seen a lot of guys
who have a killer set in front of maybe
10 people and the audios bad the videos
not that great the waitress is talking
right next to the camera you can't
really hear and even though in their
minds and on stage they just had a great
set the audience you know on their
laptops or their phones watching this at
home they don't know that and all they
see is a bad video and it can hurt you I
would not share it too quickly I would I
know it's tough because a lot of times
you have the best set of your life and
he didn't record it and then sometimes
you got all these cameras in there and
you set up the record and he didn't have
a great set so it's kind of like kind of
capture lightning in a bottle
you gotta try to make both those things
happen and and I just see a lot you know
I follow the comedians on Facebook and
stuff and I see a lot of guys sharing
stuff that you know I would have waited
a little while yeah are you seeing cuz
you've been doing comedy since the mid
90s and even you would with coronavirus
going on right now I know you had a trip
plan to LA to be like pitching a pilot
and do all these shows and everything
but it seems like your strategy is now
just doubling down on content with your
podcast and all the media you're sharing
is that does that is that the move right
now for us comedians yeah I think that's
the move right now for not even during a
pandemic I think and that's the point I
was trying to make it I forgot was like
yeah you guys need to be doing and I
need to be doing more than just working
on stand-up because the game has changed
man it's different I didn't uh you know
I didn't start with the internet I
didn't it didn't exist so I didn't have
to worry about coming up with a funny
15-second video every day or something
like that I just had to focus on the
performance of in the material and
getting on stage whereas now if you're
not doing both you're gonna be left in
the dark so you really really have to
create content online whether it be a
show like yours right here or a podcast
or just coming up with funny sketches
with some friends find a thing and do
both that's what I would tell people now
but yeah it's tough I've been fortunate
because during this pandemic I have been
focusing a lot on my podcast and my
Facebook presence and and it's kind of
fun like I have more time to focus on
that than I ever have and and I think in
a weird way the advantage of this whole
thing is I'm getting better at that and
I'm having fun dude I've been doing
tik-tok videos with my mom you've gone
there dancing yeah blog and talking with
her and taking questions and working on
the country-ish podcast
and make a tic TOCs and it's been a lot
of fun but I'm ready for this to be over
so I can go back on the road
yeah and how how mindful just to think
about the name of your podcast being
country-ish and you being I won't say
typecast but almost like known as the
southern comedian and you playing the
Hemi guy where they cast you is like
we're looking for someone that's white
trash but yet you're this guy with three
degrees so it's like where is Airy is
there any conflict with like how your
brand has evolved or is it just
something you've leaned into and just
like embrace as just natural yeah it's
something that came out of necessity I
didn't even really think of myself as a
country redneck person yeah and you know
I moved to Los Angeles in 2000 when
people told me oh no you're a redneck
what butBut I'm not they go now yeah you
are and I go well but I know real
rednecks and I'm not that but I sound
that way I looked that way and some of
my best friends are that my I thought
like well you know I got a but I kind of
got my feet in both worlds you know when
I moved I was in LA 18 years and it was
I had to get I had to figure out
something to let them know like yes I
know I sound dumb to you people but this
is how this is just my accident this is
just how I talk so I had to develop
jokes and material around that just to
get past that and get on with the actual
jokes of material I've wanted to do so
it's something that came out of
necessity I've never really thought
myself as one of the other I'm deaf you
know I'm not a redneck but I'm not Joe
Hollywood you know I'm not like some
city slicker either I gotta figure out
I'm just weird weird hybrid of both and
I think really a lot of people are a
combination it really depends on your
percentages like I would say when I
lived in Los Angeles I was like I'd say
like 65% more Metro than Jethro and then
when I came back to Hickory it's it's
balanced out a little bit like 5050
right now you know but I think it's
levels and that's why my first album was
called Metro Jethro and this podcast is
called country-ish because i'm kind of
country but not really yeah
is that nothing comedians need now more
than ever maybe with how much comedy
there is out there and for me personally
like my comedy special is called the
trophy husband and I I've really been
leaning into like that brand if you will
but this is also coming after doing
comedy for 10 years so it's like I'm not
I'm not delusional I think I figured out
comedy I mean I've been headlining and
doing more comedy zone gigs and things
like that lately but like I'm just
scratching the surface only 10 years in
but is it part of the job of comedy is
like what is my angle in this how can I
stand out from everyone it helps it
helps you I mean I don't know I think in
the beginning you know from like the
first five years you just gotta learn to
to do the craft write the jokes get
comfortable on stage and then over time
you you'll start to see a pattern you're
like oh I noticed that they're
responding to this better than this and
so I will go there and then over time
it's like oh I guess I got for me it
wasn't really even being country it
wasn't like a lot of my dad's stories
huh like I could really talk about my
dad for an hour I mean one of the
biggest bits I have is a bit about my
dad trying to fix a hole in the bottom
of the swimming pool by wearing a
backpack full of rocks and trying to
brief garden hose
my dad has nearly died so many times and
I have all these great stories about it
and you know that was like the first
thing I realized oh I'm maybe I'm the
guy that does dad stories you know
but then when I moved it away they're
like oh no but you're a redneck I'm like
okay well let's go there then so I've
really just sort of went with the flow
but I think it does help if you have a
clear idea of if you already know what
you kind of are what your brand is see
that most people
the first five seven years don't even
have the luxury of knowing what their
brand is or will be right you just used
to be in funny and comfortable up there
and then you kind of figure it out over
time but you know there are some people
who just who never figure that out but
if you can figure it out I think it will
help you succeed quicker and you you
being in LA that long I mean who were
who are the comedian's you kind of came
up with and developed with well when I
first got there I moved out there in
2000 I worked at the Comedy Store I know
a guy who was already working there
buddy of mine named Jeff Richards very
funny comedian we started comedy around
the same time at goodnights and Raleigh
North Carolina and he moved out to LA
about six months to a year before me and
so when I moved when I went out there to
visit I just crashed with him and he was
already working at the Comedy Store and
he says well come here I'll get you in
the Comedy Store get you a job I was
checking IDs and then they they make you
yeah it's like a door guy yeah and they
make you a non-paid regular which means
you can check IDs you can work the door
and then if no one shows up and they
need someone to run up on stage that's
your time and so you just kind of feel
in the gaps and then you do a showcase
for Mitzi shore that's probably Shores
mom who runs the store at the time she
would approve you as a paid regular or
not and then you would then you'd be
like in that sort of weird graduating
class so in my graduating class I guess
you could say that the times that were
hanging out there at the beginning you
had you know Jeff Richards you had Steve
burn you had oh my god they're Bobby Lee
you know Sebastian Maniscalco god I'm
figuring so many people I know that they
see everybody there yeah because it's
like the fraternity house for comedians
they've got three different rooms of
comedy going off simultaneously and
everyone goes there comedians like to go
there and hang out
if they're not performing because when
you're a headliner and you go on the
road you don't get to see the other
headliners that maybe you started with
because you know it's like ships passing
in the night but when you go to the
Comedy Store it's a Tuesday Wednesday
everyone's hanging out because they're
not working and then they'll go the
Comedy Store and do work on a new set or
just hang out but I mean you name it
I've worked with them all like I've had
to follow Andrew Dice Clay I've worked
you know shared the same stage with
Chris Rock Dave Chappelle Pauly Shore
everybody yeah I mean it's crazy
what was that you said the Andrew Dice
Clay was tough to follow what up what
happened with that
well we're polar opposites and but I
love Andrew Dice Clay I mean when I was
a kid before doing stand-up I think I
was like 19 years old he had an album
come out
it was a double cassette tape album
called the day the laughter died oh yeah
familiar with this yeah it was produced
by Rick Rubin too and they filmed it at
Dangerfield's or you recorded at
Dangerfield in front of like 10 people
that didn't know he's gonna be there
that's right and he slowly walked the
whole route right and it's one of my
favorite albums ever
I had it memorized and so I was a huge
man sheets okay
I mean just as a kid I didn't even think
I was gonna be a stand-up I just loved
comedy and he was one guys that you know
we we thought was hilarious you know
anyway now here I am at the Comedy Store
and and he's up there and then he has to
introduce me and he doesn't know me
we've never met but that's how they do
it you know each comedian goes up in
those 15 minutes and it brings out the
next guy and so he just he brought me up
and he had just murdered he just done
great and I was like man I love Andrew
Dice Clay I'm a huge fan what are Pia
what if he wasn't from the Bronx or the
New York what if he was actually from
the south what would he sound like and I
started trying to do my impression of
Andrew Dice Clay as a southern man and
then the audience what they're like do
your thing buddy inspired
it took me about ten minutes to win him
over and in a 15-minute scent oh yeah
and that that is a lesson every
committee has to learn is like do your
thing
don't try to adapt to whatever happened
before you just do you and bring the
audience to you it's a tough skill to
hone yeah I mean that was I should have
spent ten minutes trying to do figure
that out I could have made one junk
that's I mean that's another thing that
they do at the Comedy Store it's almost
like it's almost like a given that
whoever is in front of you is going to
introduce you and they might they might
do a jab they might do a quick little
ball bust on you and then when you go
out there it's your turn to do that back
but you don't do it for 15 minutes you
did you say a 1/32 thing then you just
move on that's totally acceptable I
think what I did was just I didn't know
what I was doing you know I was I was
starstruck because it was Andrew Dice
Clay that's so gnarly oh my gosh so
let's uh let's get into these questions
here let's get into some fan questions
I've hogged enough time but did you work
with Mitch Hedberg coming up by the way
I did one time he was the headliner at
goodnights I think I was the I was the
emcee of the feature I care I think I
was the emcee yes and he this was on his
downward spiral you know he was getting
really heavy into drugs and he immediate
he had sold-out shows and did great but
I remember after I came offstage the in
the feature act goes onstage and the
manager of goodnights is like John have
you seen Mitch I don't know where he's
at
we have you seen him I'm like no I don't
know where he's at he goes alright well
if the feature ad gets done and he's
still not here I need you to go up there
and just do more stuff until we figure
it out I'm like oh but I'm out of stuff
right I don't care don't come off that
stage until I tell you I'm like oh okay
then I went on stage after the feature
act was done
oh I'm sorry actually he he showed up
right before the theater had got done
and he walked in
you know I love Mitch but this is true
story he walked in with a phone book and
he had like powder on it and he was
licking the powder off and doing like
this and he's like I'd get that guy off
stage let's go I'm ready right now let's
go go go go get him on stage and they're
like okay and then he goes up there and
murders for 45 minutes to an hour and
then he left he didn't do any kind of
mean greedy didn't sell any merchandise
he just bolted but he was really heavily
heavy into an addiction at that point
and he he died probably maybe a year
later oh man yeah yeah but I did get to
see him work and it was it was great
there was no one like Mitch Hedberg for
sure yeah I always like to ask people
who have been out on the road and that
grind like you like I've had Tom Rhodes
on here asking him about Mitch as well
like he was just one of my favorites so
I always like to know who got to cross
paths with him and just connect so very
nice I wish I would I didn't get a
chance to connect but yeah I mean he was
just so far going but I did get to enjoy
him life that was nice
that was fun are there any comics that
you've been able to like work with or
connect with or learn from where you're
just like I can't believe this like I've
been I'm at a point my comedy career I'm
actually co-workers with people like
this and maybe what have you learned
from them yeah I mean definitely the
beginning let's see here George Lopez
actually came through Raleigh and was
very very nice to me I was starting to
get really good as a MC in a feature and
he was like Dan a man that you got
something going on here you should
really think about doing this you know
for a living and gave me some advice and
told me to look him up when I got to LA
and all that stuff and then same thing
with Rodney Carrington Rodney Carrington
came through good nights and we just hit
it off really good and then we hung out
and you know I told him some ideas I had
for jokes and he goes oh yeah that's
good you should use that and then and
then fast-forward later I ended up on a
sitcom which is kind of crazy but yeah I
mean the see here trying to think was
this you know it was Chris Rock actually
gave me a huge compliment one time this
was at the Comedy Store it wasn't even a
compliment is more of like he proved me
right about an argument I was having
with other comedians like me and some of
my other comedians were just kind of
hanging out in the parking lot of the
comedy store and we were arguing about
who we think is the best blue collar
comedian you know between Ron white Jeff
Foxworthy Larry the Cable Guy Bill
Engvall we were like arguing everybody
had a different guy and then Chris Rock
happened to overhear our conversation
and he walked up and he taught me my
show is like he's rap it's him he's rap
and there's just and then just went and
went away
so I don't know there's a lot of people
in the beginning you learn from but then
at some point you gotta you know you
gotta just take it on your own and who
were you write about who did you say I
didn't say oh I don't want to upset
anybody but here was our argument one
guy said Foxworthy and I go well yeah he
goes well without Foxworthy know those
other guys would have been what they are
because he was he was the main headliner
that started the whole thing and then
one guy said no it's Larry the Cable Guy
he's obviously sold so many records and
had so many specials and you know he's
down with Disney he's the voice of mater
and all this stuff and I said well I
think it's Ron white because he's
actually closer to the real deal then
another one's for me and plus you know
he likes to have a good time like me so
yeah and Chris Rock agreed with me but
that's just our opinion and no one said
Bill Engvall is that one guy did but I
forgot yeah yeah my favorite my favorite
Ron ride story you have is when you were
like opening for him and you had to go
pick him up from the hotel and he
answered the door with a joint he's like
we gonna be late and that that's just
the everybody who's ever worked with Ron
white
one Ron White story like that because
he's he's a real deal man oh dude when I
got to I got to host for him one time at
the old Atlanta punchline I remember
singing the greenroom with him and I
just remember he just goes if this was
20 years ago I'd be in here banging a
waitress right in front of you okay and
that was like my first time working with
a comedian at his level and I'm just
like oh I guess we made it if he's
saying that in front of me you know is I
feel like a comedian now yeah that's
great
so this this ties into the first fan
question as well this is DJ Underwood
who says were there any southern
comedians that influenced you or that
were your heroes growing up well you
know this goes back to my point original
I never looked at myself as a country
redneck southern comedian I happen to be
from this area and have this accent but
that's not I didn't look up to that I
mean unless you count Andy Griffith I
love The Andy Griffith Show I love Don
Knotts
those guys are southern but you know in
terms of the comedian I may be honest
with you the first one that really
inspired me was Bill Cosby hmm what was
it a guy well he was uh he made my dad
laugh and I remember we could watch his
special hit a special called Bill Cosby
himself and he came out on stage and
just told these amazing stories and it
was clean and the whole family could sit
there and watch it and laugh and I
remember thinking wow that guy's making
my dad laugh really hard I want to be
able to do that and so Bill Cosby was
the first comedian that sort of made me
want to try this or or think about it
you know or fantasize about it and then
as I got older it was you know Steve
Martin and I loved a lot and even when I
was a kid you know a lot of kids would
watch Sunday morning cartoons
you know I would watch Jerry Lewis and
Dean Martin movies
to me Jerry Lewis was basically a human
cartoon he was hilarious and so it was
never really like a big southern
comedian I just happen to like what I
liked sorry I just had next no you're
good but as I got older and I started
realizing oh I actually am redneck to
other people and I got lumped into that
category then I started watching the
other ones and then I started to
appreciate him I didn't grow up that way
mm-hmm good question like Rodney kept me
Rodney Carrington to me is one of the
funniest human beings on the plate face
of the planet and that's what I'm
familiar with his name and I know he
sells out and kills it everywhere he
goes but he's honestly it's funny he's
kind of like um it's kind of like a
James Gregory and that they found an
audience and can sell out but still most
people may have never heard of them you
know it's like they found an audience
and just can kill with it yeah yes true
I mean rodney started in like oklahoma
texas and just you know it's weird there
are people from texas who are who can
make a great living and no one know who
they are outside of texas that's how big
that status but it's crazy yeah
definitely Carrington was one of those
guys he had a lot of sold a lot of
Records back when people were selling
records you could actually sell music a
lot of funny songs and he was on radio
stations non-stop with john-boy and
Billy and Bob and Tom and all the big
syndicated radio shows and he just got
big that way he got a sitcom for a
couple of seasons and then and then that
was it but he still sells out everywhere
he goes
anytime he goes there it's crazy I see
him I see him
his tours tour schedule I'm like wow
this is amazing he's he's able to keep
keep this up
yeah I'd like to I'd like to find that
crowd I like to be able to do that yeah
what do you think the secret is to
finding that crowd that's a good
question I don't know I mean I think
it's you got to connect with your fans
and you got to stay in touch with them
like I think really got to do a lot of
meeting and greeting and and one-on-one
now with social media and stuff like
that you're really going to be on top of
that game too I think it's that and
having having a different like those
guys that we're talking about are very
good storytellers and not so much joke
tellers and I admired both you know I'm
like hey if you're making people laugh
at the end of the day I don't care how
you do it yeah but the difference
between a joke teller and a storyteller
is if you hear a joke one time then
that's it you you know you might tell
that joke to someone else but you can't
keep telling the same joke over and over
again because people go yeah you just
told that or whatever I've already heard
it you know but a story can live forever
because a good story
it's got jokes in it it's got you act
things out there's characters in it
sometimes it involves over time and
people will say oh my god I hope he
tells this one again because I remember
loving that story I forgot how it goes
it's so long that it's not just one joke
and so a good storyteller can have a
career like that that can tell the same
stories over and over again and no one
care yeah Bert Kreischer a prime example
with his machine story it's like people
want to hear it every single show right
there that Brad Regan has jokes stories
like that where people want to hear
those stories again you know and
sometimes they won't even they get mad
if you try new stuff hmm and that was
your big breakthrough is when you
finally told that story of you getting
kicked out of the Carolina Panthers game
that was kind of the moment in your
comedy we were like oh there's like
another layer to this that I can do yeah
that was sort of the whole reason why I
had the confidence to get on stage to
begin with was that that happening and
you know it was one of the first things
that I talked about that was a story
that started with
a story and not like a series of jokes
or one joke and then over to you know
over time telling the story many times
you learn the funny parts and you've
learned although there's a joke
opportunity in here and there so you
sort of write jokes around the story as
opposed to coming up with a joke and
creating a bunch of jokes that that
might lead to a story it's like I don't
know that's one of the big yeah I'm a
storyteller guy and I like I like real
things that happen and it's just easier
for me it's also harder for to steal
jokes from you if it's something that
happened and it's so bizarre and crazy
that will only work in a story that
people can't take I can never take Bert
Kreischer as a machine story because
people would you know be like well
that's ridiculous that's that's Bert's
story as opposed to one joke let's let's
get into the storytelling a little bit
deeper here because that's something as
comedians especially me trying to like
peel back another layer in my comedy and
be more kind of autobiographical and
storytelling how what is the process
behind like this is a funny event that
happened in life like your Carolina
Panthers but then how do you translate
to stage that's something a lot of
people to understand is comedies a new
language that you have to translate your
life experiences into so what was the
process of this funny thing happened and
now it's like a laughs laughs laughs
laughs laughs laughs right okay so for
example the Carolina Panther story
there's a lot of things in there that I
thought were funny to mention in the
story you just gotta kind of like in
your head you got to tell it to yourself
a couple of times maybe even throw it on
some friends and don't tell them that
I'm thinking I'm I would never tell a
friend hey do you think this is funny
and then trying out because right right
away they're like no so I would just
sort of like in random conversation
throw the story out there and if it
happens to you your friends are gonna
are gonna want to know about it so
you're gonna get used to telling this
story because this is a big thing that
happened so in the telling of the story
off
you gotta kind of learn and pay
attention to what what what was funny
what wasn't funny and blah blah blah and
then you just got to take it to the
stage and well one thing I found that
helps later on I found out this later on
was sometimes it's better to start with
the punchline if it's a long story so I
wouldn't go up there like oh so in 1995
me and my friends went to a Panther game
I start the story with I got kicked out
of a Carolina Panthers game for dancing
in the end zone with the mascot and
people go what then do you tell the
story it's not like you kind of kit you
grab their attention right away with a
major headline and then you give them
bits as you go well here's what happened
you know
although otherwise if you're just
telling a story from the beginning
you could lose people good hook and then
to find those details is it you just
tell it as it happened and then over
time you pay attention to what gets a
laugh there and a laugh there cuz you
mentioned seeing be able to add jokes
throughout it where do you find those
yeah a couple ways after telling it a
couple of times you know it's trial and
error and then after telling it a couple
times you'll listen to what the crowd
laughed at what they did and know that
well that worked and then if you record
your set you know and you go back and
listen to it you can think oh man I
should have said this because sometimes
you're on stage and you're performing it
you're not a hundred percent in your
brain thinking of a new approach to it
but if you're outside of it and you're
listening to it later you can really
dissect it and come up with jokes that
you wouldn't have thought of otherwise
so that's one way of doing it another
way over time the more and more you get
and a crowd laughs at something that you
didn't expect
and then you just improv a little bit
and see where that road takes you
sometimes that can lead to some comedy
gold
sometimes it can't but it's trial and
error mm-hmm awesome yeah and a DJ said
yeah that's what Burt does with his
machine
stories he hooks them in with got
involved with Russian mafia and then
breaks it down from there so yeah yeah
that's gold
awesome and listening to the set go
ahead
jokes are different I think you want you
want the joke if it's just a joke I
think you want the punchline to be a
crazy twist that they didn't see coming
at the end but if it's a story I think
it's okay to sort of lead with the the
craziest thing and then break it down
yeah and this this is actually something
I was curious as well this comes from
Trent Babb who asked do you rehearse
looking at the mirror I did at the
beginning because I thought that's what
you were supposed to do and I was
interested to see what I look like
before I had a video camera but no
that's not that's really not good
because when you're on stage you're not
looking at yourself you're looking at
the crowd you know just the other day I
I was I watch the movie Joker not long
ago with my mom and the new Joker it's
really good yeah and he reminded me of
the the movie uh Robert De Niro did his
Rupert Pupkin and I forgot the name of
that movie okay know anything king of
comedy Scorsese movie yeah yeah so there
were some elements of that in Joker but
the point I'm trying to make is if you
noticed Rupert pumpkins basement his
wallpaper was a crowd of people looking
at him and that's more realistic than
looking into a mirror so ya know that is
what such thing I yeah I wonder cuz your
voice is so distinct if you were like
rehearsing it offstage because it is
more of like how you're saying things
adds a whole new layer of humor beyond
just the actual verbage of what you're
saying and that's a compliment by the
way being able to elevate your material
like that is very challenging yeah I
mean I don't know I always always
enjoyed the kind of comics that that
used everything not just words but their
face their whole body nuances I liked
all of it and then sometimes you don't
prepare for that you just get up there
and you're telling a story and you make
a face that you didn't think was funny
but they did and then it gets a laugh
and you go oh I could hold that for
another two seconds mm-hmm anything to
get laughter I mean that is the the goal
for comedians laughter all right in this
next question yes remember kids it has
to be funny funny above everything first
okay great yeah a lot of the times it's
like I want to have a cool attitude
onstage well it's like well be funny be
funny first let's see the next question
here this is from Dede and she asks of
course you want to murder but don't you
think you did your job if only a few
people laugh what makes you say I did
good
well if only a few people laugh and a
room full of 500 that's not good
but if only a few people that room a few
people that's great so it depends on how
many people are in the crowd but you
want the percentages to be more people
laughing than not now yeah I would say
murdering is 98 to 100 percent of
everyone laughing very hard that they
can't breathe
that's murdering but you can you can
still have a great set and only get
about fifty five percent that are
laughing so hard to can't breathe and
then that will that will also make other
people laugh sometimes and then they'll
feel like well why am I not getting this
I why is this guy laughing so hard and
I'm not I don't know but maybe it's
something I'm not getting
but yeah I mean a few people is not
murdering I mean you can feel good about
yourself but I wouldn't share that tape
with everyone because it's not as good
it will never be as good to other people
as it was for you because you were in
your body when it was happy
and you were experiencing all that love
there just at home
ODEs are driving and they're looking at
the car they're looking at looking at
you and it's like what what is this so
it needs to be I feel like that that
question was from a from a comedian
she'll need it needs to be if you want
to share it and you want people to like
it and think you're good at what you do
it needs to be a good quality video but
keep at it yeah that was something Nate
bargatze said when we did a Q&A with him
was like being in New York and seeing a
comic like bomb and he was gonna be like
it's alright man yeah I struggled with
him too but then the comic got off and
was like yeah that was a good show and
he was like what that was awful he's
like you bombed I mean he didn't say it
to him but he's like remember him he
said that was a moment for him in his
career where he was like oh some people
just aren't even listening to the
audience right and they're delusional
right at the really I mean as as a
comedian I want people laughing mm-hmm
and if that's not happening then I'm not
a comedian
maybe I'm something else and I could
make a career that maybe I'm a good
public speaker maybe I'm a you know
maybe I'm good at roasting or something
but if they're not laughing then that's
it's something different as a comedian I
won't laughter as do I so let's just a
few more questions here
the next like Trent actually had a
follow-up on the storytelling with do
you ever find your stories get bigger
laughs from the characters reactions as
opposed to your inner thoughts hmm
phrase say ask me that again yeah let's
see here do you find your stories get
bigger laughs from the character
reactions as opposed to your inner
thoughts some maybe it's saying like do
you find there's more laughter when you
take them to the moment and create that
interaction as opposed to I remember
this thing happening that time at that
place when he said this you then take us
to that moment of him saying it and you
make it
I think people like it anytime in a
story if you if you take on the role of
other characters like you know people
say oh this guy does a good impression
of George Bush well everyone knows who
that is but if I said oh and my dad and
I started getting into what my dad
sounds like and what what that is that's
a character even though they don't know
who it is it's something different than
the way I sound now and you're acting it
out it's it's another layer in your
story so yeah sometimes the characters
that I portray in the story gets bigger
laughs than me telling a joke or another
random thing people seem to like it when
I do my dad a lot you know when I when I
take on my dad's persona and it's really
not even that close to what he sounds
like I just thought this is a funny
sounding thing right if I were doing an
impression of my dad and people knew my
dad you'd be like he doesn't sound like
that but the people don't know my dad so
they just have to believe me but I think
that's what they were asking I'm not
sure if I answered the question yeah it
seems like that's what it is like do you
find more like laughter creating
characters as opposed to like maybe
having like an inner monologue with the
audience maybe type like I feel like the
more I feel like yeah act outs and
characters add a new dimension to your
stand-up and make it more of like a show
as opposed to like a monologue and again
this is just what has worked for me you
know there might be other people who
don't do that and do I mean there are
tons of people who don't do that and are
very successful and very funny I'm only
telling you what has worked for me I do
what I love about you saying that I've
interviewed over 200 comedians and it
that has been a common theme of it is
like this show is all about comedy
advice but most comics are like now this
is what worked for me I'm not saying
this is the law this is how I did it but
it may not work for you
or you won't Melanie a piece of it may
work for you like there's no one way in
this comedy game a hundred percent I
didn't know that I when I wanted to be a
comedian I didn't know I was going to be
a southern sort of country a
storytelling comedian because I didn't I
had no idea what my how I was going to
be on stage I just knew that I made my
friends laugh and I like making my
friends left can I do that in front of
strangers on a stage let's go for it and
over time I just figured it out but you
know that's just what works for me I
don't know everyone's path is different
everyone strengths or difference are
different everyone's weaknesses are
different so you're just gonna figure
out what your strength is and then you
know go for it
whoo that's gold figure out your
strengths and then go for it how long
into your career cuz you've been doing
since the mid 90s and I've been doing it
like just little over ten years and I
still feel like I'm just like scratching
the surface on figuring out this comedy
thing when did you start to be like oh I
think I'm getting into a rhythm here I
think I'm starting to figure out at
least like the basics of this like how
long did it take you to get that
confidence I got I got lucky again I
came up at a time where I was able to
get a lot of stage time for not being a
you know New York or LA comic I mean
Raleigh at the time good nights and
maybe one or two other spots was the
only place to do comedy but I was doing
a lot of hosting doing a lot of emceeing
so I got a lot of reps in and I was
high-energy way more than I am now they
like you know comedy clubs like
high-energy acts if you're not you know
if you're not already famous and don't
already have a fan base and you're some
no-name off the street they like it if
you're high-energy because it makes the
crowd and engage and everyone has you
know it's just more fun I think for them
but so I was higher energy and I got a
lot of work but I think oh okay I can
tell you what was
so I was probably doing maybe had two
years under my belt doing comedy I
wasn't a feature act yet but I knew I
had 30 minutes in me but I'd never done
30 minutes at one time I had ten here
I'd done seven here I'd done fifteen
here different stuff but I've never
pasted together and the it was a
Wednesday night at good nights
the headliner did not show up and the
club owner was like well let's move the
feature act a headliner let's move John
to feature John you could do 30 minutes
right I'm like you betcha boss and so I
knew I could I just had never done it
and and it just happened to be the
headliner happened to be a black
comedian and the whole room was all all
black people and you know that was
intimidating for me because I'd never
experienced that and I used to dance on
stage I used to make fun of dancing by
dancing I used to call myself dance
machine and I'm on stage and do random
stupid dances like you know shovel rake
mop did my favorite dance I did was one
called
any guy washing women's laundry in the
1800's dance very abstract but I all
this I hadn't I hadn't set to music I
had every dance had its own song and it
was all tired out and to my own credit I
could I could dance I got rhythm and so
I would on stage and I started dancing
and I still think to this day there is
nothing funny nothing funnier to an
all-black room than a white guy dancing
and they loved it and I was dancing
there and then I got done dancing and
then I started getting in my routine and
they're like no no we need you to dance
again that and it would sort of taper
off at the end it was losing momentum I
just go hit it Paul
like that was the DJ hit it Paul and
then he'd play music and I started
dancing again but it did that was the
first time I did 30 minutes and it was
the first time where I got big laughs
and then it tapered off and I got him
again like it was a journey 30 minutes
and and it made me realize oh I could do
this I could do this if I did this again
over and over again I could figure this
out and that was a that was a that was
one pivotal moment that I'll never
forget is like okay I could figure this
out this was this was not too bad it was
actually really good and and I learned
from that but yeah that was that was a
big one yeah big yeah that's a big
benchmark for all comics when we do have
shows where you overcame the odds and
survived right like this isn't as bad
yeah Oh DJ said you have to do a dance
video calling out Bert and Tom you
should do that man believe me I've
already thought of it come on there's a
though their dances are not really like
I gotta be honest with you I I can dance
better than them but their dances are
funny and they're very highly produced
and they spend a lot of money on those
videos and let me just tell you they
will out budget me in these videos I
will not be able to keep up money-wise
with the the product they're churning
out but if it were straight up dance
competition I I could do that but I I
like to be funny with it you know and
there actually is a video on YouTube
that people wanted to see it I retired
my dances like one one day I just said
okay I'm not gonna be that guy anymore
I'm just gonna focus on better stories
and better jokes and I'm getting older
and I didn't want to dance every show
and so I did one show a big theater and
I said and I recorded I said this is the
last time that I'm ever dancing and I
recorded it and it's on YouTube right
now if you type in go to youtube and
look up the hickory dance machine or
hickory dancing nut you'll see it
how long a career was that it's just me
on stage it's not like you know it's not
like a music video it's just me
performing in front of an audience that
that that one last time how long into
your career was that where you're like I
don't want to dance anymore uh probably
around 2005 2006 so about ten years into
it I guess you were like all right
enough dancing yeah I'm done with that
I'm done with that part nothing wrong
with it I was honestly just getting
tired exhausting and I was kind of
growing it it looked weirder I mean as a
young man it's kind of funny kind of kid
like oh look at that guy he's got rhythm
he could dance not bad for a white boy
and then you get in your 30s and 40s
people like oh man this is weird why is
he dancing you know so God just that to
me in my opinion I felt like I'm just
gonna be done with that that and that's
what I was looking for when asking about
like when you felt like you were getting
to another level is like me ten years in
I'm like okay I'm ready to like up the
level a little bit like my writings
always been there but now it's like what
I want to get more in storytelling a
more performance and that like I like
how you said about ten years in is when
you're like alright I'm ready to make it
like rial most like reassess what I want
to do with comedy so I'm glad you had
that around the same time so that's
reassuring and really my whole career
started with dancing I was dancing at
the Carolina Panthers game with the
mascot got the whole ball rolling and I
thought well let me take it to the stage
I'll show what I was doing at the
Panther game and I'll come up with other
dumb dances and had a whole routine
about dancing and I just she started
getting out of shape yeah DJ said you
could do it at a trailer park and lean
into the low-budget video vibe oh yeah
that'd be good yeah just go do it like
well it's funny a Zach Galifianakis a
while back it's not this is not dancing
but he did he lives in North Carolina
yeah
I don't know
but he's from Wilkesboro North Carolina
has a farm and he he shot his own music
video to a Kanye West song and that was
kind of neat because it was the two
opposites coming together you know which
I thought was cool and that I would love
to if I'm gonna do that dance video and
I've thought about and I've had other
people bring it up to me like oh you
need to you need to call out Bert and
Tom yeah I would like to I just know I
would I would want to do it really good
and it would take me forever and I would
have to employ people and editing backup
dancers all this crap and I'm like
really for a 30-second video I don't
know but a sometimes that goes viral
just from the phone like you know a
tick-tock calling them out maybe all it
takes to you know what I mean a
tick-tock with your mom calling out Bert
and Tom and you're both making fun of
them in some way like it could be that
simple that strikes fire you know yeah
and then maybe now you're dancing on
stage again it just comes full circle
now you're known as the dancing machine
yeah all right
there's the time to do that because in a
weird way I just had a doctor's
appointment not long ago it's just a
routine checkup
you know just happened to be during this
Corona crisis and he goes well you look
really good because what do you been
doing I'm like well I can't go to Planet
Fitness anymore because they're close
but my brother who is a health fanatic
he's a CrossFit fanatic you know he made
a gym and of his garage and I've been
going over there and since I can't go
anywhere else that's all I've been doing
and so this pandemic I'm the healthiest
I've ever been because of this pandemic
so maybe now it is time to bring back
the dancers well you heard it here first
hot breath averse this is where it
started hot breath so let's yeah just
just like two more questions here and
we'll get you on and out so you can
start rehearsing your dance to take on
Burke and Tom
Gregory Hardy says let's see do you have
any memories you'd like to share of
doing Gator Bowl in 2008 as a University
of Florida guy I was thrilled when I
heard you mention it and another talk
you did yeah yeah that was crazy that is
the biggest audience that I've ever
performed in front of like a live
audience human beings it was the Gator
growl is the biggest pep rally in
college sports they they hire big bands
they have big comedians come in every
year I mean it's been going on I mean
Bob Hope was one of the first guys to do
it you've had tons of comedians over the
years big names that you know I feel
like so just Seinfeld talk about it I
think I've heard him talk about doing it
yeah Jim Gaffigan Seinfeld you name it
man did there's a lot of big names and
I'm like wow this is going to be crazy
god I'm trying to think of who that oh
god the band the band was big - oh they
sing Abra Abra Cadabra hawa jad and grab
yeah oh who is that man anyway they were
there and so I got had to go him first
and I want to say it's probably like
35,000 people made 35,000 people yeah
because they do it they do it in the
football stadium they have a stage set
up in the end zone and the audience just
fills in the seats so however many
people come there for the pep rally
that's how many people and that thing
you know it probably holds like 50,000
but it was about 35 maybe 30,000 people
as a lot of people but the weird thing
about it was there was no one
immediately in front of you so I had no
one no crowd because they had manicured
the field for the game they didn't want
people on the field so no one was on the
field well I'm in the end zone looking
at an empty field the crowd isn't a
shoehorn around me in the stands and
their yards away so you trying to look
someone in the eye
and have a moment with him telling a
joke is not an option and I remember
asking Jim Gaffigan like well do you
have any tips for me to do this he goes
well just know that the crowd is so big
and so far away from you that the say it
takes a moment for the sound to carry so
you'll do a joke
and you're probably used to getting
laughter immediately but that won't
happen even if the even if the joke
worked you're not going to know it for
about three seconds so it'll be like you
tell a joke a boom punchline and it'd be
like in your head you go on one and the
crowd goes because I was laughs but that
first three seconds are scary because
you don't know if it worked and you're
just standing there waiting so what I
did do was play to the camera they had a
camera guy close to the stage and so I
would look right into the camera and
they had your face on these giant
screens behind you that people in the
stands could see so really you're just
playing to the camera guy and hoping
that people in the stands are listening
and getting the joke but that was Tim
Tebow's last year at Florida State that
was his senior year and it was a really
cool man there were really nice to me I
had a good time there I can't imagine
the high after that cuz you know killing
in front of 300 people you're buzzing
but thirty five thousand you must have
been high for like a month right yeah it
was crazy
just one gig I had to do 15 minutes hmm
thank God I don't know what I've done
longer than that but it was fun I made
fun of Tim Tebow a little bit and they
they aprea went along with her do they
take offense to it I mean I really just
sort of I had football jokes so it just
changed the name yeah yeah because you
played you played football so and now I
play football high school and then I've
got kicked out of a football game so
I've got a love you know it was easy for
me to do that gig it made sense I had
just one last comic standing so it was I
was at my peak I guess and DJ
had referenced as well of like your
storytelling style does it come from
being in the locker room and things like
that do you adapt it from that mmm
I don't think it's like a room in
anything do I think it's more of just
you know that's just what I grew up
listening to with Bill Cosby and those
kind of people I don't know I don't know
why I think I'm well in a weird way I
think it's harder it's you got to be
more clever to write really good jokes
where you can actually go up there and
tell jokes and not have to act anything
out and just go joke joke joke and that
and that do well you have to be very
clever and very smart and that'd be a
great vocabulary and be very succinct
whereas that's just not the kind of
human being I am so I have to like I say
play to my strengths which is making a
goofy face and tell him a story and
being likable and moving around and you
know that kind of stuff so unfortunately
I did not acquire that skill but I
admire those who can but you have skills
other people don't so yeah it's very
good overall note from this is to
discover what your skill and strengths
are and just double down on them so yeah
and people are saying the Steve Miller
Band was that's Steve Miller was a
believer yes so - these are two quick
ones to end on here kiddos thank you to
everyone that tuned in and asked your
questions and of course thank you to
John for your valuable time here the
first one Jody Carter is who is your
favorite who are your favorite current
comics okay so I use a guy named Brent
Blakeney he opens for me a lot on the
road met him in Raleigh very funny guy
we did we did a show in on New York
together last year
oh very good yeah six feet seven inches
tall right so he's he serves many
purposes for me now
great comedian and fun to be around but
you know he's like my built-in bodyguard
yeah so so I like Britt also love a guy
named dusty slate who's really on fire
right now
from Nashville and has been toured
around and I've known him for years and
he's doing really well right now so
those are my two favorites at the moment
that people might not know about
yeah and Dusty's been he did a Q&A and
he also did an interview with us a few
years ago as well so yeah good good dude
great dude
yeah in a good time as he says well
there you go this is an example of a guy
who found his niche and it's just going
for it
right exactly smart guy from a trailer
park and has the branding with the thing
like it's all like very smart very smart
but organic you could tell tracks I
think what people appreciate about is
that it's authentic he's not trying to
play a facade it's all authentic to him
and he's just self-aware enough right it
just happened organic like you're right
it happened on stage he just found
himself doing that and that's getting an
extra laugh I thought well I guess I
should talk about why I do this and it
just became a thing he didn't think well
I need a thing how about this he just
noticed he was doing it and then made
that the thing mm-hmm
yeah all right so the final one here
it's kind of a two-parter I'll combine
between John Chappell and Dee Dee
because they're kind of along the same
lines but John asks can you say Hickory
the DeeDee asked I have to ask this but
does that thing got a Hemi yes see
that's another thing that came that just
happened and it became a thing you know
so so now I've had to write material
based on that I didn't want to I was
just an actor a gun for hire and that
commercial happened and Here I am but
yeah
that's crazy how that caught on I just
don't get that all the time
incredible oh and didi says gold I just
loved how at this point you're like yes
it's like you don't even act out
anything you're just like yes is it that
isn't annoying at this point like yeah
I'll tell you it's yes it is a little
bit because I mean that's just my own
thing I gotta get over there but what's
what's really good about it is it's a
question so someone had walked up and
said hey Hickory you know I just go
what's up or like him a guy but when
they say does that thing got a Hemi my
brain has to answer the question and so
I'm compelled I'm like sometimes I'd
like depends on what mood I am I've had
a good but I go yeah man sure does or if
I'm gonna bad my like no it does what's
thingy talking about my penis
yeah I think power PT so I like I've
always answered the question differently
depending on my mood and problem is is
it's a question if it weren't a question
it wouldn't bother me so much because it
revokes a response you have to say
cycling right and I imagine all the
traveling you do and there's times
you're tired and rundown and you've got
to be like Hickory or you know wow yeah
well funny Hickory used to be a
punchline in my gym I act I used to use
it as a joke of whatever but now because
because of Last Comic Standing
they showed me saying Hickory over and
over again every episode so it looked
like that thought it looked like this
that I talked about what really that was
one thing that they aired over and over
again but I and coming up next the guy
from Hickory and so I couldn't make it a
punchline anymore because people already
knew about it so then what I would do is
I come on stage in some town you know in
another state and I would go everybody
good to be here I'm not from here I'm
for
and then do like this and now the crowd
goes half cry they do it so in a weird
way like that has totally changed
it's totally shifted and started as a
punch line now it's like an audience
like it's a call to action they'll
they'll do it yeah and then I just move
on oh you get it out of the way almost
that's cool get all the way up front it
was like hey he said it and then I can
move on
great well yay first off I'm gonna play
the applause sound effect yay for all
that you said today John you killed this
and you were more than generous with
your time so this is a show all about
like comedy education and helping comics
and all that so the final thing is like
is there any advice you've learned over
your twenty plus years of experience or
anything you can kind of share with us
and closing here to propel us into being
better comedians this is a you want me
to give advice to other comedians I
would say take two weeks off and quit we
got enough comedian better and move
right there
young keep people quit you're in the way
there's enough of us love that no I
don't know figure out what you're good
at and stay in that Lane I mean it's
okay obviously okay to take risk that's
what this whole job is but if you want
quick success I would say it's all about
repetitions the more you can do it the
better you're gonna get the quicker
you'll get there record yourself figure
out what worked what didn't and you know
have fun and at the end of the day
please try to remember your job is to
get laughs peers know that I see a lot
of people not not caring about that
anymore and if it makes me sad I'm like
well this is good I wouldn't call this a
comedy special I would call this a
variant
formative lecture but I didn't laugh
that hard you know you need to stand out
to you that didn't tickle your fancy
well there's there's a couple on Netflix
then that I'm watching a like ah okay
and this is this is very informative
like I said this can be a good TED talk
but no I'm not laughing like okay a lot
of people if you ask a lot of comedians
don't say who were some of your favorite
comedians and everyone will say at some
point say George Carlin you know and
yeah he was one of the best he had tons
of specials in his very beginning years
in his early years was very very funny
but the older he got the more you know
more order he got angry and and I found
myself watching his light his last
special I found myself doing this and I
go oh man yeah he's right that's true
and not this see I want to get the laugh
so I wasn't he wasn't making me laugh in
the end but I don't know but by that
time he was already legend it didn't
matter but I don't know I guess I said
too much no it's almost like he had
found his audience and could just like
almost preach to them as opposed to like
when you're younger and you're having to
prove yourself there's I'm sure there's
a more of a fire beneath your creativity
when you almost have to create success
but when you already have the success it
must be hard to withhold that standard
to a degree yeah
I would encourage younger comics to to
go for the laughs first and then and
then later on after you found your
audience then you could get lazy
breach breach all right yes so get funny
first kids focus on getting funny first
and that's I'm a pierced as well like
funny above everything is is my mo so
it's so great to connect with a funny
comic like you John if you could let
them know where they can support you and
follow you and all that jazz my podcast
if everyone would go to this website
country-ish pod
cast calm country-ish podcast I'm very
proud of it we have new episodes every
Friday it's on Google it's everywhere
Apple Apple podcast Spotify Pandora
iHeartRadio anywhere you get a podcast
it's there it's on YouTube as well check
it out give it a chance and then pass it
on and thanks buddy thanks for having me
John and I definitely think a lot of
comedians have podcasts where they're
just like shooting shooting the [ __ ]
with each other but like I your approach
is you're doing like an actual show
production you have a set you have
segments like I think it's important for
comics to look at John's approach to
podcasting and treating it like an
actual production and not just like a
hangout session with your friends it's
it's it's yeah those are fine but the
ones that work as hangout sessions are
people who already have an audience
right you know I'm gonna get new people
listen II need you just to hang out so
to grow your podcast I think it would be
good to have segments I'm still trying
to learn that game too though I can't
really preach too hard about that but
I'm only on episode 21 and we're loving
it man
so I hope you guys watching this give me
a chance
yes go support go check out John he's
doing big things so Jon REEP thank you
so much for being on hot breath my man
ladies and gentlemen we will be back on
Monday with a Q&A with Alonzo Bodden so
Oh Alonzo Bodden was a judge on my
season the Last Comic Standing I'm a
huge fan what I definitely will
alright hopper at the verse we'll see
you on Monday stay funny